she's a cold-blooded Beast it's not your
fault that you are losing your hair
hello I'm Brandon Flowers from the
killers this is lab Bibles life advice
I've got your questions here here we go
this one is from Amy from Edinburgh you
say Edinburgh Edinburgh how does that
make any sense it's my wedding coming up
and I want to surprise my fiancee by
writing a song can you give me an
opening line damn this one might be
better for Ronnie come to me is it is a
good opening line come to me your face
looks like come to me so this is Jono
from Manchester I don't know if it's
Johnno or Joe know JOA know Jonah I've
started balding and my girlfriend has
given me the ultimatum that I get a hair
transplant treatment or she's going
elsewhere what should I do
she's a cold-blooded beast it's not your
fault that you are losing your hair and
some people actually look more
distinguished and even more handsome
some women like bald men so you might
have to go get yourself one of those I'm
a recent vegetarian this is from Kevin
from nodding nodding him not and nodding
and I'm a recent vegetarian but my
boyfriend insists I eat his homemade
sausage at least once before I fully
commit to the cause
how do I handle the sticky sausage
situation oh man this is just full of
wonderful innuendos a sticky sausage
situation
this guy's messing with me
go vegetarian to stay away from sausage
[Music]